in 2021 Facebook's reputation was rocked
by allegations made by a former employee
turned whistleblower Francis Howden
claimed Facebook knew it was causing
harm to society but still prioritized
profits over people she said Instagram
was even more dangerous the question now
has met her the company that owns both
Facebook and Instagram even tried to
make the platform safer I've been
speaking to Dex Hunter toric of the
oversight board which tries to keep meta
and its boss Mark Zuckerberg in check
thanks thanks for coming on the show
great to be here um first of all can we
talk about you and your background
um can you give our viewers an idea of
which big companies you've worked at and
what you're doing now uh sure I mean I
started my career at the UN actually as
a policy guy and I made the transition
of its working in Silicon Valley
um after a couple of years in a very
large impenetrable bureaucracy I thought
I want to go work with folks who are
trying to change the world and maybe do
it in a little faster paced way so I
ended up at Google after that I was at
Facebook and then I went to work for
Elon Musk at SpaceX and I've been in
Communications and public policy for
about 15 years and I'm now at a body
called the oversight board which is a
independent body that was originally
created by meta in 2020 and we operate
as an independent Watchdog essentially
which looks at some of the controversial
content issues on Facebook and Instagram
So Meta owns Facebook and it owns
Instagram two of the world's biggest uh
platforms what sort of oversight do you
perform what do you actually do yeah so
there are billions of people using
Facebook and Instagram and every day a
lot of people are seeing their content
moderated by the company so you may post
something that's then taken down by the
company you may see something on the
platform which you want to see removed
and which you think violates the rules
which might harm users Visa issues which
you can appeal to the company but if you
don't get satisfaction from meta you can
then appeal onto the oversight board and
an independent body a set of members
we've got 23 uh folks from around the
world they make decisions then about
whether that content should be removed
or restored from the platform and we
also make recommendations on how to fix
meta systems and and Dex for many people
watching this interview especially those
perhaps with children I've got to myself
one is on social media one's a little
bit too little yet to do that
there is for some parents a sort of
feeling of helplessness about keeping
your kids safe from the toxic effects of
social media do you accept that for many
people social media has been a negative
and many of them feel utterly powerless
to sort of control that environment or
keep their children safe you see that
that is a problem absolutely I mean I
think there are a lot of people who are
very very concerned about how to you
know protect their children online and
uh every day there are people facing all
sorts of horrendous abuse of course
social media also has huge positives um
you know I think we often take it for
granted uh in Western Democratic
countries you know the value that having
access to speech um you know being able
to communicate in this scale can have
for people
um but absolutely there are problems
we've got to deal with them otherwise we
will lose the promise of social media
and in terms of sort of concerns there
was also the issue of Donald Trump and
uh he's now been reinstated on Facebook
and Instagram that was meta's decision I
was under the overseas board wasn't
involved in that decision that's not
that's not something that the board
would get involved with so we did
actually have a role um so in 2021 of
course uh Donald Trump was suspended
from Facebook and Instagram after the
events of January 6. and uh the company
subsequently asked the board to decide
was that suspension correct and the
board made a decision there we actually
said although it was right that uh
president Trump had been suspended it
was an indefinite suspension and that
was wrong it was a penalty that wasn't
actually contained in meta's rules they
basically invented this penalty with no
criteria for when they imposed it or
lifted it so we told the company the
process you use to impose these kinds of
penalties is as important as the
decision and we sent it back to the
company they subsequently imposed a
two-year suspension which um they've
just announced is being lifted okay so
you said regardless of the rights of
wrong of the case you can't just be your
own arborist is you have to have a
process that's right it's been now weeks
after the John 6 house committee report
concluded that that Trump directed
encourage and support an attempt to
overthrow American democracy matter
though then concluded after this
two-year time
threshold that the risk to Public Safety
have diminished when it comes to Trump
and that's just as he launches a new bid
for presidency you had nothing to say
about this as the board why so from the
board side we don't want to speak about
this currently because we may end up
jeopardizing a future decision if this
comes back to the board so this is
actually for us a question of remaining
neutral and impartial before we
potentially have to deal with this in
the future so what's the trigger for a
further suspension yeah I mean I think
it would be if there's a future Grievous
breach of the rules that are designed to
protect users on the platform it's the
house report includes more than 50
references to Facebook highlighting how
his Trump and his followers spread false
claims shared them encouraged people to
head to DC to stop the steel and used
often Facebook you'll know this to do it
how troubled are the oversight board
about the house accusing Facebook and
other social media companies of
amplifying lies and radicalizing that's
to quote quote the house report the
house of represents
radicalizing consumers uh we are
absolutely concerned about that and
actually the board has previously uh
told the company that they should commit
to an independent investigation of any
role that the company's platforms may
have played in amplifying that kind of
content we of course said it was right
to suspend Donald Trump in 2021 so this
is something that we're going to
continue focusing on very very carefully
what did they say when you recommended
an independent investment they actually
didn't commit to that but they did
commit to talking to external
researchers and working with them to be
concerned about it it's quite toothless
isn't it if you recommend an independent
investigation into what happened because
it was potentially egregious breach of
rules with with profound consequences
and then Mets just ignore you I mean it
makes you a bit of a toothless board
doesn't it I don't think so I mean you
see you see the point I think you could
absolutely make that argument but I I
don't think it's quite right there's a
there's another sort of layer to this
because the Whistleblower Francis uh
Hogan came forward in 21 with the
troubling account of what happened
around Jones so she said Facebook
understood the danger of the 2020
election turned on Safety Systems to
reduce misinformation which they called
Civic integrity and as soon as the
election was over turned them back off
we'll change the setting back to what
they were before to prioritize what she
described as growth over safety and that
was the environment in which Facebook
played a key role in the events of John
VI that's quite a betrayal of democracy
isn't it I think you could absolutely
make that argument so Francis Haugen I
think she had a very important role to
play in demanding transparency from the
company but from the board side we spoke
to Francis howgan a couple of times we
certainly found the site she provided
incredibly helpful and it actually
guided how we investigated the company
to just come on to something else it's
not just about sort of democracy and
politics if we come on to children to
quote Francis again she also taught
about the price being paid potentially
by young people and she brought to light
internal and studies from inside much
that revealed that 13.5 percent of teen
girls say Instagram makes thoughts of
suicide worse and 17 of teen girls that
say Instagram makes Eating Disorders
worse
that's that's unacceptable isn't it
absolutely and this is an area which the
company should absolutely be committing
to work much more closely with
researchers it's something which
regulators and governments also need to
be taking a firm stand on so what would
you like to see Dax I mean you're an
expert in this field what do you think
they could do to actually affect change
because I'm sure people watching this
with teenagers like my own
think well what could the companies
actually do to to make this a more
positive environment for their young
people who you can't get off these
websites to be honest you can't get them
off the social media sites even if you
want to yeah sure unless you put them in
a cave just lock them up take away all
their technology well there's a concept
that we have been talking about in the
tech industry and in conversations with
policy makers for many years around the
concept of media literacy and how people
should actually be navigating through
online spaces which present all sorts of
harms and
um certainly I have never seen any
example anywhere in the world of
effective media literacy programs being
rolled out at scale it's something where
frankly governments need to you know up
their game as well but it's something
where companies should be made to commit
resources to it's a dangerous new world
out there we need to raise young people
to be prepared to navigate these spaces
Haven sums up she says Facebook's
realize that if they change the
algorithm to be safe for people spend
less time on the site they'll click on
less ads they'll make less money is that
is that right I'm not sure that's true
um you know actually when you have
environments which are harmful to people
which promote polarization which promote
harms
um lots of people will get disengaged
consumers aren't blind to this stuff
um
and just just just to finish off on on
this and some of the stuff that Francis
Haugen said
um there was the case of Molly Russell
which you will know she consumed content
on sites including Instagram that
focused on self-harm and suicide she
took her own life at the age of 14. how
troubled
Were You by that being in this space and
the ill effects it had on this
particular young person uh I don't think
anybody with a conscience or a soul
could not be uh troubled by this it was
obviously something that revealed a
terribly evil type of content out there
and also a failure of the systems that
were used by the company there so it's
absolutely something which I think
should be a wake-up call uh to
governments as well as the tech industry
on why we need to move faster and Dex
What did the what half the tax industry
done about it so I understand one of the
big things in the Online safety bill is
actually outlawing an entire content of
self-harm content it's also something
where we understand meta has put in new
restrictions as well and they've beefed
up enforcement there but I think the
proof's going to be in the pudding does
it actually stop young people
self-harming does it remove that content
and would you like to see media literacy
in the perhaps in the online harmful but
would you like to see that legislated
for I would absolutely absolutely it's
something that I think should be an
urgent priority for us and of course we
know the next generation of Technology
tools like AI things like the metaverse
they're going to present all sorts of
issues as well would you be in for
technology companies funding those sorts
of programs I think if your business
model relies on uh connecting a lot of
consumers and you're making a lot of
money from that you have an obligation
to invest in the protections for those
users as well so you could you wouldn't
you you could see a sort of a specific
tax for something like that potentially
I think it's something we should
certainly investigate just on keeping
young people safe I have to bring up
Andrew Tate his violent misogyny finding
its way onto computer some phones of
boys across the world I have a teenage
boy he and all of his friends seem to
know about Andrew Tate I don't know how
it has somehow uh gone into the
consciousness of these young men but it
has it has met and maintain a ban on him
but your former boss Elon Musk is a loud
Tate to spread his poison on Twitter you
know mask
is he fit to run a social media platform
I think we'll have to wait and see how
Twitter evolves over the coming months
and years
um certainly I think lots of people
including myself are very very concerned
at some of the unpredictable changes
that have happened to the platform Dex
you've you've worked for Elon Musk you
know well you've worked for Mark
Zuckerberg you know him well do you
think email us as a character is someone
that should have a huge social media
platform I mean he's somebody who
obviously feels very passionate about
freedom of expression at the same time
he's somebody who's got his own very
strong point of view and uh social media
is if nothing else about managing very
diverse communities with a lot of
interest which you are chilon must to
take Tate off Twitter I would yes
so you think you should take Tate of
Twitter and and what about other
companies such as Facebook and Instagram
should they be doing more to stop the
sharing of Tate material on their
platforms yeah I mean um there is
content that is incredibly harmful I
think we need to look at on a
case-by-case basis but certainly where
there is a record there's a track record
well built up of incredibly harmful
things being applied to a whole
generation of people um we need to take
action we can't just be talking about it
what why would you like to see him taken
off though Tate I mean it's uh exactly
as you pointed out Beth there's a person
here who has been spreading incredibly
uh terrible misogynistic harmful content
to lots of people
um and these are the sorts of online
harms that I think uh there is a very
strong consensus in society including
the policy makers and the tech industry
that we need to take more action on
so you think it should be joined up with
government and the company's policy
makers absolutely need to work with the
tech industry uh these are problems that
we can't simply ask the tech industry to
solve on their own we need leadership as
well from politicians Dex thank you so
much
um for giving me your time it's a very
fascinating conversation I appreciate it
thanks Beth thank you